MIKE COLEMAN: Hi.
I'm Mike Coleman, a developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
In this video, we're
going to take a look
at what might be the quickest
way to move workloads running
in VMs onto containers.
Specifically, I'll
be showing you
how you can utilize
our migration
tools to move your existing
VM-based workloads to Cloud
Run, Google Cloud's fully
managed serverless platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before we get into the details
on Cloud Run and our migration
tooling, let's level
set by what we mean when
we use the term "serverless."
Serverless platforms
allow developers
to abstract infrastructure
management for a simpler
developer experience.
With serverless tools, tasks
like managing the underlying
infrastructure are
handled by Google Cloud.
This infrastructure scales
dynamically as needed.
By handling these
day-to-day tasks,
you're freed up to focus
on additional value
added tasks, which
can ultimately
increase your speed to market.
Cloud Run allows you
to develop and deploy
highly scalable,
containerised applications
on a fully managed
serverless platform that
allows you to deploy
containerised workloads
in seconds.
In addition to
reduced complexity,
Cloud Run also offers
several key benefits,
including increased security via
automatic HTTPS and flexibility
with custom domains.
You can write your code using
your favorite language--
Go, Python, Java,
Ruby, and more.
It's built upon the container
and Knative open standards,
enabling portability
of your applications.
And you can abstract away
all infrastructure management
for a simpler
developer experience.
When looking at modernizing
existing workloads,
I like to break it down
into two big buckets.
The first is the modernization
of the underlying
infrastructure, such as
running workloads on Cloud Run.
The second is modernizing
your existing workloads.
One way to do that is to
take an application that
is running inside of
a VM and convert it
to run inside of a container.
Migrate for GKE
and Serverless is
a set of services that
helps with that process
by automating a significant
chunk of that work.
When looking at migrating
an existing workload,
there are four discrete steps
that you'll want to go through.
First, discovery
and assessment--
Migrate has a fit
assessment tool
that can be used
to help identify
what workloads you have
running and which are
best candidates for migration.
Take a look at
our fit assessment
video for more information.
Next is the setup
and planning phase.
Migrated workloads can
be run on Cloud Run,
as well as in GKE in Standard
or Autopilot mode, or on Anthos.
Additionally, you can
orchestrate migration pipelines
to help automate the
migration process.
In this video, we're
focused on the third phase.
So I won't spend a lot
of time on it right here.
The final phase deals with
how you manage applications
after they've been migrated.
Because Migrate for
GKE and Serverless
provides you with the
resulting Docker file,
you can easily manage
updates to your code
via standard
deployment pipelines.
To illustrate how
Migrate for Serverless
works with Cloud Run,
I'm going to show you
a demo of taking a Django
application's web front
end from a VM and
running it on Cloud Run.
We're actually joining
the migration process
in the middle.
The application was
originally a monolithic VM
that had a front end and the
database running together
in the single VM.
We use Google Cloud's
Database Migration Service
to move the database
to Cloud SQL,
and the web front
end is still in a VM.
In this demo, I'll use
Migrate for Serverless
to move the Django
application out of the VM
and into a container that
I will deploy to Cloud Run.
To start the demo, I'll provide
Migrate for GKE and Serverless
a source VM.
The Migrate processes
will inspect the VM
and then generate
a migration plan
that I will edit as needed.
From there, it will generate
the deployment artifacts,
including a Docker container.
Once we have that container,
I'll deploy that to Cloud Run.
With that background,
let's take a look
at the process in action.
Let's start by taking a look
at our application in action.
So it's basically just a
database of Unicode characters.
So if I click on
the waving hand,
I can see different characters
for different operating
systems.
Now, because this is
Django application,
we are using Nginx and
Gunicorn in tandem,
where we have Gunicorn
running on a socket,
and we bind that to a port
that Nginx is listening on.
We're going to need to change
that in our application.
And all of that is
being served out
of this virtual
machine, which I'm
going to shut down right now.
Shutting down the VM is a
prerequisite to migrating it.
So let me stop that
VM, and we'll get on
with the actual migration.
With the VM stopped, let's go
ahead and create our migration.
So I'll click Create Migration,
give the migration a name,
select a source, which
I created earlier,
choose Linux system
container for the workload
type, the Django GCE
instance, and we're just going
to migrate the base image.
So that's going to take
a couple of minutes.
I'm going to go ahead
and stop the video,
and I'll join you
when it's finished.
All right, we're finished
now, so let me go ahead
and review and edit
my migration plan.
The first thing
I need to do is I
need to set this value
to True so that we
can use our enhanced runtime
and run on Cloud Run.
I also want to disable
all these services.
Some of these are used for
that Gunicorn Nginx pattern
that we talked about earlier.
Other are services
that I don't actually
want to run in
production, such as SSH.
So I'm going to
disable all of these.
And when I have all
of those disabled,
I can come down here and click
Save and generate artifacts.
That's going to generate
the Docker file as well
as a couple of Docker container
images, which I will eventually
deploy onto Cloud Run.
So let me go ahead down here.
I'll click Save and
generate artifacts.
Again, this takes
a little bit, so I
will fast-forward the video and
rejoin you when it's finished.
OK, we've generated
those artifacts.
So let's go ahead and
move back over here
and take a look at
what we've generated.
So if I click on Review
Artifacts, we can come in.
And we talked about
before-- here's
a Docker file, a
Kubernetes deployment spec,
as well as the
container image base
layer and the runtime layer.
So we're going to go ahead and
move into Cloud Shell here.
I'll use migctl to
download my artifacts.
And I can list them out
here, and you can see them.
Now, services-config.yaml is a
file that we can use to define
services that we want to
run in our new container.
And I'm going to use that to
define the Gunicorn service
ingress.
So this replaces sort of
the systemd configuration
we looked at earlier.
Since I want to include
this updated services-config
in my new container, I'm going
to go ahead and run Cloud Build
to rebuild my container image.
And that's going to incorporate
that services-config
and give me a new version
of my container image
that I can deploy
into Cloud Run.
So let's let this finish here.
I'll speed it up a little bit.
With that container
image created,
let's move into Cloud Run and
create a new Cloud Run service.
So we're going to come in here.
We choose that container
image we just updated.
We're going to scroll
down and we're going
to set an environment variable.
That environment
variable tells Cloud Run
that we're using the enhanced
runtime from the Migrate
for Containers system.
So let's go in and
set that to True.
Then we're going
to come in here.
We're going to define the
connection to our Cloud SQL
database.
So we'll select that there.
And then we're going
to come in here
and we're going to allow
unauthenticated invocations so
that we can reach the
service more easily.
This will take a
second to deploy,
so let's let it run
through its thing.
We've got the URL.
I'm going to paste it up
here and create a new tab.
Let me grab that, and new tab.
And there's our application
running on Cloud Run.
You can see everything working
as you would expect it to.
Well, I hope this
video showed you
how you can use Google
Cloud's Migrate tooling
to move applications out
of VMs and into Cloud Run.
For more information, check
out our documentation,
and be sure to
like and subscribe
so you'll be alerted whenever
we publish new content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]